we find that half of all of our
measurements show people's attention to
be less than 40 seconds yes of course
sometimes we spend longer but half the
time that we're on our devices our
attention spans are 40 seconds or less
in duration
I would guess that managing my attention
and the associated trials and
tribulations that I go through trying to
achieve that is probably the most common
challenge that I face on a daily basis
and I also think that it's one that a
lot of other people will resonate with
as well they don't need to be a
podcaster but just attention is
something that feels to me to be
slipping through my fingers on a second
by second basis
yeah and and that's what our research
shows and I've been studying this for a
very long time for about two decades and
uh yeah you you are not alone there are
many many people who share your concern
given that you've been studying it for
quite a while have you looked at any
longitudinal stuff to do with this if we
had degradation over time as it was now
than it was 20 years ago yes as a matter
of fact I I have so I I first started
studying this back in 2004 and what led
me to study this was I noticed my own
attention was becoming problematic and I
found myself
switching from Project to project and
you know app to app and web page to web
page and I wondered if it was just me
and I started talking to other people
other people started mentioning similar
kinds of things so you know being a
researcher and a psychologist I thought
I can study this empirically and find
out if it's just me so at the time back
in 2004 we used pretty primitive
technology to measure this we we used
stopwatch so we would click the
stopwatch every time a person shifted
screens and it you know it's very
accurate but it was very laborious and
you know it took a long time but we were
able to get objective results and back
then we found attention was about two
and a half minutes
on any screen before people switch to
another screen at the time it astounded
me
but I kept measuring this and then
computer logging techniques were
invented which made the process so much
easier they again could get very
objective measures of how long people
are on any computer or phone screen
around 2011 we found attention spans to
decline to about 75 seconds what was
that first one was two and a half
minutes two and a half minutes down to
about a minute and 15 seconds
uh and this is on on average and in the
last five six years we find it's about
it's reached a steady state of about 47
seconds on any screen before switching
um this has also been replicated by
others who found results within a few
seconds so it it seems to be that our
attention spans have diminished and and
let me present another way to look at
this which I think is
um you know makes makes you see this
perhaps more clearly if you look at the
median of our measurements that means
the midpoint the midpoint we find that
half of all of our measurements
show people's attention to be less than
40 seconds
so you know yes of course sometimes we
spend longer but half the time that
we're on our devices our attention spans
are 40 seconds or less in duration that
is absolutely terrifying
it is and uh you know I I was surprised
back in 2004 uh but I I am continued to
be amazed
what has happened over the last 20 years
that has had the biggest impact on our
attention
I'm not sure we can say there's one
single influence there there's so many
things
um there are
uh of course there are individual
differences some people happen to be
better at self-regulation than others
there are it's the fact that we're
social beings are it's our social
Natures don't forget social media that
the big one Facebook came along in 2003
and because of us being social creatures
we're just drawn to wanting to
communicate with others I wonder what
would have happened if you'd started
your research a decade earlier I wonder
if you would have seen a real inflection
at Facebook because that was kind of a
step change right yeah I mean it's such
a great question and I really wish that
others had been studying this so that we
could track this much longer so um you
know unfortunately we we don't know
because we don't have the data what do
most people get wrong when it comes to
thinking about how attention and
distraction works
so there are several things there there
are some myths I think one myth is that
we tend to blame all of our distractions
on notifications targeted algorithms and
that is certainly a source absolutely
can't deny it but it turns out that
people are just as likely to interrupt
themselves so about half the time people
interrupt themselves and so we can't
just blame it on on something external
to us but also there's something within
us uh so that's that's definitely and
another thing
um and maybe we can spend some more time
talking about it is that people tend to
think of us of our attention as being in
two states you're focused or not focused
it turns out there's it's a lot more
nuanced and complicated than that
given that around about half of our
distractions are self-generated and yet
we've seen attention go from two and a
half minutes to 75 seconds to 43 seconds
over the last 20 years our nature hasn't
changed so what it would suggest is if
50 of an increased number of
distractions the calls coming from
inside the house that there is an
interrelationship between the changes
that we've seen environmentally that are
now engendering some kind of internal
state which is causing us to distract
ourselves more quickly is that fair to
say I I think that's exactly right I I
think you've you've nailed that right so
it's it's who we are as as humans we
have social Natures we have particular
personality types and there's this
interaction with the environment the the
digital world that we live in
um and let me let me also point out that
it's not just computers and phones where
we see attention spans to be short but
it turns out that other media that we
watch things like TV and film The Shot
lights of TV and film have also
decreased over time and they average now
four seconds to have a look at um I
think it's Fast and Furious nine
no I think
I may be misquoted on this I think that
Fast and Furious 9 is the Blockbuster
that has been released with the highest
number of scene cuts ever oh it could be
yeah for precisely that reason a tick
tock generation that goes swipe swipe
swipe swipe that kind of pace
see the internet can hear that we're
talking about it swipe yeah that pace of
um it's reflecting
like a pace like a Cadence a Tempo that
people have got themselves used to when
it comes to dealing with anything on a
screen and that's now it's so crazy that
the use of social media has impacted our
expectations of what we see on a screen
which has then caused movies which have
been around for much longer to have to
reverse engineer our own new overclocked
nature yeah so it's that's an
interesting way to put it but we have to
be really careful we can't make a causal
claim we can't say that the faster shot
changes in TV and film have caused our
attention spans we can't say our
attention spans have caused that these
are two parallel Trends
um the way I interpret it is that when
you watched even TV and film it just
reinforces us to have these short
changes and we we don't know what's
causing TV and film to be to switch so
fast it could be that directors and the
editors themselves are influenced by
their short attention spans we're all
Downstream from Steven Spielberg's
attention span imagine that yes yes
um you know or it could be that they're
gearing their editing based on what they
think would the audience will respond to
or it could be something else but we
there we can't say a causality but it's
it's a really interesting Trend I I
think that one one thing that I I do
believe has an effect is that
um social media platforms constrain the
length of content that we can post right
it constrains our text uh you know
Twitter
um the length of videos like Tick Tock
and and I do feel that this has an
influence you know so people are used to
having short Snippets of content right
they're used to snacking on social media
and and I do feel that this has an
effect this interrelationship between us
uh the predisposition that the human
mind has for how attention works that
has now potentially
bro signs being reinforced or weaponized
or utilized by an Ever speeding up
technology uh input and then is now
starting to reinforce
going back to absolute Basics let's say
that somebody has no idea how our
attention system works why do we have an
attention system what is it what what
does it mean what are the nuts and bolts
of attention well you know attention
helps us survive in the world right and
there are different types of attention
there's conscious attention when you
know you're really intentional about you
know where you're paying uh where you're
paying attention to but there's also
automatic attention and when we reach
for our phones when we go to check email
or check social media that's an
automatic kind of attention like we're
we're just not really aware of that so
there there's that
um and you know there's the the father
of uh psychology William James
has this wonderful quote he says
everyone knows what attention is right
it's it's using your your conscious
awareness devoting it to to something
and I would say of course we know what
attention is we can't always control it
right there's a distinction between
knowing what it is and knowing uh where
to control it but you know we have so
many things on the internet uh and
ultimately the human mind is a
bottleneck we we can't possibly take in
all that information and so we're we're
faced with our our humanness and
figuring out what you know what what we
can attend to what we can't and
sometimes it
gives us problems yes because there is
more that we can attend to than we have
capacity to attend to that's right means
that we have this task switching
attentional distraction I remember once
hearing someone describe it the same way
they've modeled how squirrels forage for
food and they said that humans forage
for information in a similar sort of way
oh this is something new oh this is
something oh this is something yeah you
get one headline and half a paragraph
into a news article before you decide to
go to something else because there might
be something even better so okay you
come up with I think a slightly novel
way to categorize different types of
attention this sort of layer of four
what are those different types right so
um I mentioned that you know most people
tend to think there's two states of
attention you're focused or not focused
it's it's a lot more nuanced and when I
first started studying this I realized
you know you can pay attention to
something and be challenged so you know
if I'm writing I'm really using effort
in writing and I'm engaged in it and we
have humans have a limited amount of
resources cognitive resources you can
call it mental resources attentional
resources it's our capacity of attention
okay and if you're doing focused work
you're using a lot of those resources
but we can also be engaged in something
and not use much of our resources an
example is playing Solitaire or you know
I have an anagram game that I'd like to
play it's easy but I'm really engaged in
it and I'm not really putting in a lot
of effort it's not challenging
if you're not engaged or challenged
that's a state of boredom right we all
experience boredom at times and if
you're challenged with something and not
at all engaged we call that frustration
an example is when I have a tech problem
it really frustrates me and I'm just not
engaged in it at all I don't want to
deal with it but I have to right and as
a result it gets me frustrated so those
are the four types
which quadrant is are people the most
fulfilled or the happiest then and which
are they the least happy in yeah so
surprising it turns out when people are
engaged with something but they're not
challenged right we call this rote
attention or rote activity turns out
people are the happiest they feel the
most positive when they do this why
because it's easy people like to do
what's easy very often when you play
these simple kinds of games you get
rewards and you get rewarded very fast
and it you know brings people positive
feelings
um and you know strangely enough they're
happier than when they're focused why
because when you're focused it involves
some amount of stress right it can be
very fulfilling but it falls stress on
the other hand people are the most
unhappy well of course when they're
frustrated and also when they're bored
right in fact
um it's it's really interesting because
when you're bored you're not using any
of these mental resources and as a
result you you have to devote them
somewhere and you devote them to paying
attention to time
right and so that's why when you're
bored you're always looking at your
watch you're looking at the clock
because you have to be you know thinking
of something and so we tend to think of
time
is rote attention why people will go
when they're on social media is that
engaged but not challenged yes most of
the time I would say yes I mean
obviously there are times you can be on
social media and you're
using some amount of mental effort but
most of the time it's just you know easy
uh Road kinds of activity what's kinetic
attention then because you come up with
this term too yeah so you know I
mentioned that you know half the time
our observations show people spend 40
seconds or less on any screen
and you know I was very intrigued by
that and of course I I observed a lot of
people and you know I observe them
switching their attention so fast and
checking something and scrolling and uh
and I was looking for a word to describe
that kind of attention Behavior it's
Dynamic and so in physics the term
kinetic uh just seemed to explain it
very well so you know much of the time
that we're on our screens we we use this
kind of kinetic attention you know which
is just we're not able to uh stay on one
screen at the same time
what do you think is happening with this
prevalence of ADHD because I'm seeing
more conversations around it now is it
becoming more common I don't know
whether this is your area of expertise
or or could you imagine that it might be
common or possible for these
environmental factors to influence ADHD
so
um I can't speak to the interaction of
an individual with the ADHD and uh
certain distractors uh what I can say as
um and I wrote about this in my book
that I I did a deep dive to look at the
prevalence of ADHD and in the adult
U.S population it seems to be roughly
about eight and a half percent or so and
for uh younger people I think up through
the age of around 16 or so uh the
prevalence is higher um
I I
think it's something like 14 or so 16
um oh
maybe maybe I have those figures wrong I
think in the adult population it's four
and a half percent and I think up to the
age of 16 it's about eight and a half
percent so it's certainly prevalent but
you know I wouldn't say it's an to me
this does not suggest an epidemic I
think what what a lot of people are
thinking because I also hear these
conversations is that when people are on
their computers and phones their
behavior mimics
uh what ADHD behavior is like but it
doesn't mean that that individual has
ADHD because you can get off your
computer and you should be able to read
a book or you should be able to walk in
nature and you should be able to focus
if you don't have ADHD in other words it
seems that there's a mimicking of this
Behavior without actually having ADHD
well I think the concern that people
have when we mentioned it earlier on is
this bleed right from uh technological
relationship
with regards to attention into our
attention environment generally even
when we go away from it you know if 50
of the reason that we're distracted is
self-generated you take the technology
away you still have an increased 20-year
uh relative 20 years stat of I mean you
have
based on where it's at because it was
two and a half minutes down to less than
one minute now your 50 of self-generated
stuff would have been the same as the
entirety of your distractions including
external stuff only 20 years ago which
is absolutely crazy
um yeah I mean I was talking to my
housemate Zach earlier on and he said
dude I think I might have ADHD I was
like what makes you say that he says I
walk into rooms all the time and I don't
know why I why I've gone in I realized I
was supposed to go in for something and
I've forgotten the reason I was in there
and I said how many times when you do
that are you on your phone
and it's a lot it's a lot of the time is
in that task switching mode and as you
said the half of the number of times
that we get distracted it's less than 43
seconds yeah so you know the amount of
time it takes you to go from the kitchen
to the bathroom or wherever it was to
get whatever it is you needed yeah it
doesn't surprise me okay so
there is
there is a battle for our attention at
the moment right that that is the
attention economy is
um organizations all of which are
competing with each other Netflix
competing with Kindle competing with
audible competing with you Facebook and
Twitter and Tick Tock and everything
attention is the prime resource that you
have I suppose in that time is limited
your time on this Earth is limited and
although time is a limited resource what
you do with your time is what you mean
when you talk about time you don't talk
about time just as something that you
can go in exchange for something else
The Exchange that you make with time is
how you deploy it with whatever you're
focused on that's in front of you that's
right yeah I mean time is a precious
resource so is our attention
um the other thing to keep in mind is
when I talked about limited attentional
resources these are so precious and
every time we switch our attention think
of it as you have a tank of resources
and that tank leaks because you're you
you're expending resources when you
switch and so there's so much to pay
attention to and we utilize these mental
resources when we pay attention to
things unless of course it's simple
activity then you know we can we can
stretch our resources a bit farther one
of the things we find mind is that when
people
accumulate what's called Sleep debt
sleep debt is the accumulation of lack
of sleep night after night we find that
as sleep depth increases attention spans
decrease
so you know if you're a person you need
eight hours of sleep a night but you're
only getting six hours you're
accumulating sleep debt and what we find
is and and we've measured people over
the course of days that their attention
spans are shorter
and they what do they do they tend to do
more lightweight activities like
Facebook for example oh so they'll stay
engaged but they won't go into challenge
right because they just don't have the
mental resources available they're you
know the best one of the best things you
can do to increase your attention span
is to get good sleep
wow yeah I mean one of the interesting
things especially having done this
podcast you'll be Episode 600 or
something and over the last five years
I've got to be able to play with my
mental capacity you know I I really got
a sense now for how agile Everything
feels up here and I can usually relate
that to my inputs did I get enough
sunlight earlier on today did I sleep
well am I hydrated what's my blood sugar
level like is it going up is it going
down did I have a big meal am I stressed
am I distracted but like I ding ding
ding ding and I've got myself to the
stage now where that this is my um how
would you say primary
uh output of performance this is the
metric that I'm optimizing for right how
quickly is my brain working and what's
my verbal dexterity to deploy that like
how quickly can I get that to move and
for me as soon as I push sleep as soon
as I do
I there's a ambient anxiety that comes
in because I know that I can't perform
as well on the show today as I could
have done had I have gotten an extra
hour and a half or whatever it was I had
this big I had this huge podcast
um I went on Joe Rogan's show toward the
back end of summer and two nights before
it I was in Houston Airport and they
that all of the flights had stopped and
I got a an Uber from Houston to Austin
because I just needed to get two nights
of sleep I knew that if I had two nights
sleep in my bed that it wouldn't matter
if I didn't get in until 4am everything
would be fine so I can one I can
absolutely guarantee that it is a huge
impact when it comes to
um mental agility verbal dexterity Focus
attention even the creativity side of
stuff as well so going into um I mean
one of the topics I've discussed a
number of times on the show is to do
with multitasking multitasking versus
mono tasking uh
everyone will be familiar with this
anybody that's listening that thinks
that multitasking is even a thing and by
multitasking we mean parallel processing
right not switching from one thing to
the other
what is the elevator pitch for someone
that believes I can do two or three
things at once that will stop them from
realizing that
it's not humanly possible it's it's not
humanly possible to do two or more
things at the same time that require
mental effort
right if you're going to use conscious
attention you can only pay attention to
one thing at a time uh what people are
doing is they're switching their
attention now you can you can be
consciously aware and devote your
attention to something and then do
something automatic on the side so you
know I can be writing and there could be
easy music playing in the background but
as soon as rap music comes on I might
start listening to the lyrics and then
I'm devoting attention to that so if one
activity is automatic
like driving a car is automatic you can
talk at the same time but as soon as the
car swerves in front of you then all of
a sudden your attention is focused on
that car in front of you and you stop
talking right because now your conscious
attention is directed at that thing in
front of you so it's not humanly
possible to as you say parallel process
do two or more things that require
effort at the same time and what is the
uh red pill when it comes to
multitasking uh as in task switching
quickly just how bad and degrading is
that to the quality of our work
well it it has effects for sure so uh
first of all you know we know that
people have more errors when they
multitask and there's been studies done
with Physicians nurses Pilots that show
when they switch their attention they
make more errors uh one scary study
showed Physicians make a lot of
prescribing errors when when they
multitask uh we know that it takes more
time to finish a task because there's
something called a switch switch cost so
every time you're switching your
attention from one task to another it
takes some time to reorient to that new
task and and that's called a switch cost
and uh probably the worst news of all is
that stress increases when people
multitask so we know from Decades of
laboratory research that blood pressure
goes up when people multitask there's a
physiological marker in the body that
increases when people multitask
in my research we've used heart rate
monitors we had people wear heart rate
monitors in their offices and we've also
measured their their uh switching of
attention and we find this uh
correlation the faster the attention
switching the higher is the stress
measured and you know the last thing of
all is that when we ask people about
their perceived stress they report
higher perceived stress when they
multitask all of these measurements are
consistent and they they paint a picture
that says that multitasking is just not
a good idea if you want to be productive
if you want to be effective in your work
and you you want to have well-being
why if it's the case that multitasking
causes people to experience stress
physiologically why is it so alluring to
do multitasking I would have presumed
that we would have had this felt sense
of the blood pressure and everything
else you don't want to keep doing this
and yet people continue to do it yeah so
I would say you know there's there are
several reasons in the workplace people
just have to react the demands of their
work environment so people are by their
preference people are mono taskers
people prefer doing monochronic work
it's what makes people the happiest but
we live in a world that's polychronic
which means doing switching your
attention among multiple things so
you're in a workplace and all of a
sudden you get a slack message or email
where you should switch your attention
to something else someone comes into
your office and asks you a question so
you know it's the polychronic
environment that's causing us to switch
but there's also you know I talked about
our social Natures right we have social
Natures where we're just compelled to
want to
respond to other people because we care
about something called Social Capital
right we we want to be in good
um you know to appear uh in good well
good esteem with others and so we
respond to their messages we you know we
want to be good citizens so it's our
social Natures wrapped up in this as
well and of course
um there are individual differences with
self-regulation some people just have
this urge to be switching their
attention and that's you know it's it's
their Natures I remember reading an
article a little while ago that said
wearing noise canceling headphones in an
open plan office helps a little bit
reducing cognitive Errors By 14 but
actual silences reduces those Errors By
one-third so everybody just needs to
shut up basically I I think so yes what
about Mono tasking but being interrupted
let's say that it's not task switching
let's but there is some sort of
interruption that occurs have you looked
at that
we have so you know it's it's really
interesting so I have done a laboratory
study where I had people do a task and
in in one case they they were not
interrupted and in the other case we
gave them interruptions this same task
and we measured how long it took for
them to do the test so we subtracted the
time out from doing the interruptions
strangely enough and it's
counter-intuitive people actually
perform the task faster when they were
in the condition where they were
interrupted now a couple of things to
keep in mind uh it sounds good sounds
like it's good news for multitasking but
there was a price and the price was that
stress increased so people work faster
but the stress went up
um now the other thing this is a
laboratory experiment and people did
this over an hour but over the course of
an entire day right this uh this is just
not not not tenable
um you know there was another study done
where they had people do difficult tasks
over a six hour period which is you know
more similar to uh to a day and they
found that when you're expending your
mental resources to do something
difficult uh and it could be like
switching attention uh people had less
ability as time went on to be able to
um guard against distractions so they
they made more impulsive choices and so
you know it shows that our you know
there's parts of the mind that wear down
there's a part of the Mind called
executive function that can't function
as well as it should
and this is what we can expect when
people are multitasking
do you think it's right to use the term
Tech addiction when talking about
people's relationship to their phones
and screens
or would Tech compulsion or something
else be more accurate yeah I like to
stay away from the term addiction it's
it's a very strong word and there's
there is a very precise definition for
addiction in the medical community I
think uh compulsion is is a more
accurate uh way to explain what's going
on and to describe it that people we do
have this compulsion when we sit in
front of our screens and even when we we
don't we have this compulsion to reach
for our phones what's the difference
between an addiction and a compulsion
well you know when you have an addiction
and when it's taken away you have
withdrawal effects so and that of course
might be uh you know a lot of people
might experience that uh some people may
consider themselves addicted but um you
know I think compulsion is a softer term
to use I I like to stay away from these
kinds of extreme definitions because I I
think you know I think compulsion is
um a more apt way to describe uh and I
and I do think that people certainly
people have the capability to exert
control they can take control and
um you know when you're addicted it's a
little bit hard
to take control so I changed the wording
that I used
um about six months ago when I had Dr
Andrew hubman from Stanford on the show
and he said the exact same thing he's
sort of uh
term checked me on calling it attack
addiction he said to me it behaves much
more like a compulsion and the reason I
like that reframe as well is it it puts
the power back in your hand we can't
underestimate how important the lexical
linguistic tools that we use to describe
the things that we're doing in our lives
are right if you that's right if you
were to call it let's say a Tech Law you
know like the law of thermodynamics I
have to pick up my phone it's this sort
of um indefeatable attractor yeah that
would be even stronger right this would
be like a law of the universe but it's
not okay so why don't we not only use
more accurate language which is also as
far as I can see kind of more empowering
to the individual more sovereignty more
agentic etc etc I I do believe that
people can develop agency over their
attention so I I think you're absolutely
right I agree with with you that calling
a tele Tech compulsion
paves the way for people to be able to
develop agency to understand that they
can develop an agency
I learned from you that the guy that
invented the Internet designed the
internet to replicate the way that a
human brain works and because I did that
it it's basically too good and that's
why it's so slippery for us to get
distracted can you explain that it's
it's so ironic isn't it so the um the
idea for the web originated with an
engineer by the name of vanavar bush in
1945 and this idea was called the memex
and at the time vannavar Bush he ran a
very large scientific
research office in the U.S and he was
managing 6 000 scientists and he was
very frustrated with how information was
organized and at the time there was the
Dewey Decimal System
and he thought there's got to be a
better way and he was an innovator and
he thought information should be
designed the way people think
and that's by association
and the theory of how people's memory is
organized is according to a human
semantic Network we associate Concepts
together so you know when I think of cat
I immediately think of dog or think of
catnip or you know the name of my cat
buster
uh and so the memex idea remained an
idea but then others came along and they
built upon it and then the web was
developed and then you know of course uh
Tim berners-lee wrote the software that
made it possible to exchange all kinds
of media uh to
um you know associate nodes and links uh
so that we could share all kinds of
media now what where we are today is
that the web the way it's designed
mimics the way human memory is organized
and there are so many entry points into
our minds Network when we go on say a
Wikipedia page we'll be reading
something and it primes us with so many
different ideas and associations and
then we see a link and we've been you
know cognitively primed to be thinking
of that we click on it we read new
content and again there's just this
Firestorm of associations that goes on
in our mind we see another link click on
that and so there's this mirroring of
the behavior we're doing on the web the
way the web is organized and the way our
minds work
what has happened from what already
sounds like a pretty optimized
environment when it comes to trying to
encourage people to follow down whatever
path it is that their attention takes
them on what has happened with the
introduction of algorithms and AI
you know every time you go on the
internet
digital traces right you you like things
you comment on things you visit certain
sites and so algorithms are can be very
sophisticated to take a person's digital
information and they can be used to
Target information
that will make that person want to
respond to it so you know persons
personality can be detected uh through
algorithms and so you know advertising
can be geared to you uh notifications
can be geared to you you know if your
personality type is if you happen to be
an extrovert
um ads can be geared towards you know
what what extroverts might want to
respond to so yeah we we live in a world
where our digital information is being
used uh and incorporated into algorithms
to uh to capture our attention
the thing that I learned from Stuart
Russell guy that wrote human compatible
he's also like it's the textbook when it
comes to computer science I think he's
Mr algorithms and he wrote a book called
human compatible which is trying to
reverse engineer algorithms to be more
uh Pro human
this apps I completely lost my mind when
I learned this in his book so he said
that
the way the algorithms work is that they
are prediction engines trying to work
out what it is that you want to maximize
usually click through sometimes click
through and watch time some of the
metrics but it's like will you click on
this or will you be entrusted by this
and there's two ways that the algorithm
discovered that it could achieve this
remembering that the algorithms for the
most part are black boxes you know for
everybody saying we want to see what's
happening inside of YouTube's algorithm
their own devs don't know what's going
on that's right they don't have a clue
they just set it away with an optimizing
function and now it's this big beast
that's able to deliver funny cat videos
when you want them and right two ways to
do it right first way is you cut the
algorithm can deliver to you more
accurate predictions for what it is that
you want
the other way is to change your
preferences to be easier to predict so
there is a two-way street going on
between AI algorithms and the users of
that platform so that's right if you are
for instance able to allegedly make
individuals more partisan more extreme
in their views it is significantly
easier for you to detect what it is that
they will want because there is less
Nuance if you have someone that's in the
middle they're going to fall either side
on different points of view whereas if
you can push them out to the sides and
then when you roll on top of that we'll
get into it the desire for sort of
social approval our inherent tribal
biases you have this sort of
reinforcement mechanism and then there's
a third element that I really wish I'd
spoken to him about which is audience
capture from creators that make content
so you have this two-way relationship
right AI to user back and forth trying
to predict but also trying to reprogram
in order to make them easy to predict
but then you also have me so I am
someone who creates the content that the
algorithms are deploying to the people
and I am being influenced by what
happens and what the people that are
watching my stuff click on so there is a
concept called audience capture which
you might be familiar with where a
Creator starts to continue to feed red
meat to his audience his or her audience
they start to do what the audience they
know the audience will respond to as
opposed to what to them feels creatively
right and what you end up with having
there is an Ever more sort of
caricatured extreme one-dimensional
version of that Creator because they
back themselves into a corner of
constantly being cooked by their own
audience the audience just yes tells
them what they want to do so there is
now a third element in this uh Menage à
trois of attention distraction and yeah
I found that that two-way relationship
fascinating and then you layer on top
the Creator in the audience capture I
thought that was so interesting that's
right
um there there's so much to talk about
with the algorithms
um algorithms can be very agile and an
example of that is The Tick Tock
algorithm so Tick Tock learns very
quickly what you like and it feeds you
the videos uh based on you know what it
thinks you like then as soon as you
change and you start finding something
else of Interest the algorithm is you
know it's flexible it changes and it
starts learning what your new
preferences are so algorithms learn from
humans behavior and they adapt
this is then reinforced as you said
before by us wanting social connections
online right so
um the fact that social media is social
we have this predisposition for wanting
to be connected for wanting status for
wanting belonging so on and so forth so
this creates an incentive for us to
actually become more distracted in an
Ever more convenient world yes that's
right I mean there are so many aspects
towards social Natures uh and as you put
it so nicely the interaction between our
our social natures and the Computing
environment so I mentioned the idea of
Social Capital there's also
um identity you know people are very
concerned about their social identity
not just the identity and social media
but work identity and as a result you
know people are compelled what do you
mean when you talk about identity
so how you present yourself to others on
on the web so the the impression that
you want others to have of you so we
spend a lot of time crafting our
identities right and you know some
people spend more time than others
because that's we're concerned with
what's called impression management and
that means the impression that we want
others to have of us and sometimes you
know we have more control over our
online identity than we have over our
identities in real life absolutely yeah
you can curate your online version of
use significantly easier than you can
create the real world version of you
yeah and and that can be a a Time sink
for a lot of people and of course
there's you know there's power relations
so you know a person who's lower in the
social hierarchy tends to spend more
time looking out for messages from
someone higher up on the hierarchy so
there's so many
um things that are going on but we talk
about our social Natures that's a very
interesting element that I hadn't really
considered I've had a lot of
conversations to do with status
ancestrally and how that relates to the
modern world too
somebody who is low status I mean child
mortality outcomes that you pick what
health lifespan uh pick whatever outcome
you want basically you know the higher
your status the better your outcomes in
life for the most part right
um but another thing that you have is
that as you become higher in status you
need to apply less energy to maintaining
that identity to keeping up appearances
because you kind of move under your own
momentum if you're one of the top 10
people within your field there is less
requirement for you to constantly be
hungry and checking and what do people
think about me because people already
know about you right and yeah that's a
an element of status that I hadn't
really considered before that adds to
this power law of the the Matthew
principle right the rich get richer and
the poor get poorer yes the status will
get more status full and they get more
status full in a more easy way yes
that's right I mean there's there's so
much nuanced that's in involved with
using the internet absolutely
what's the relationship between our
personality and self-regulation
so some people were born with uh with
good self-regulation so they're lucky
they were dealt a good set of cards
others are not born so lucky just
because you're not born with good
self-regulation doesn't mean you can't
develop it you can you can develop it as
a skill but there are personality
differences we find that if a person
scores high on what's called neuroticism
there's a personality uh uh the
instrument that's the most widely used
instrument to measure personality it's
called the big five there are five
dimensions of Personality one of those
is neuroticism neuroticism is you know
you have a propensity to be stressed
neurotics tend to replay events over and
over in your mind you know oh I just
have that conversation with that person
I should have it should have played out
differently neurotics tend to have a the
shortest attention spans so you know
shorter than than others now if a person
scores high on another one of these big
five traits that's called
conscientiousness and that means that
you're very disciplined you're very
disciplined person they tend to actually
check their email more
because they don't want to let anything
get through the cracks and so you know
we find that they have they check more
frequently than others so there there do
seem to be personality differences
that's very interesting
conscientiousness is the best
personality predictor of outcomes in
life I think in terms of uh wealth and
uh
uh life achievement overall educational
outcomes as well
but there is a price that you pay for
that
uh industrious motivation to keep on
thinking about things to always be
wanting to check yeah I'm uh I'm
moderate low in euroticism but I'm quite
high in conscientiousness so I'll blame
my lack of attention on my inbuilt
personality
have you looked at the relationship
between technology and happiness how
happy people are either when using it
after using it if there's an optimal
amount if there's a a maximum amount so
I I've looked at it more at a micro
level in looking at the actions that
people do and what makes them happy so I
know there's a lot of people who've
looked at the relationship of social
media and well-being and those those
results are are pretty mixed but um we
find that when people are doing this
kind of rote activity simple mindless
kinds of activity where they're still
engaged they do tend to be the happiest
or you know it provides them a kind of
Solace
and what about have you looked at
um
the retrospective
ratings of Happiness there because that
needs to be folded in right you know the
the actions that you do and the pleasure
that it gives you
has consequences not just in the moment
but also afterward or else everybody
would just be taking MDMA and cocaine
and a cocktail on the Lilo right there
is there is not just happiness that
would be meaning as well you know there
would be satisfaction there would be
purpose it wouldn't just be the state it
would be the trait effect of doing that
and I certainly know maybe this is me
trying to find a cope for the way that I
not shame but sometimes the guilt that I
feel after I've used my phone for too
long that yeah maybe in the moment there
was a sense of pleasure and if you said
do a self-writing on how happy you are
right now like yeah I've been watching
this good video about some documentary
to do with space or something
um but if I do that for two and a half
hours the way that I feel after that is
all manner of
self-flagellating uh unhappiness so yeah
I wonder how when you smear
or aggregate Tech use across an entire
day which includes your ability to
reflect and ruminate on how much of a
piece of you are because you just
spent Forever on Tick Tock or whatever
um I wonder how that that changes
yeah so you know it's interesting you're
you're making me think of a study we did
where we looked at happiness you know
are people happier when they do social
media like Facebook uh or when they have
in person
interactions and so we we tracked people
over the course of the day and just like
you said in the moment people are
happiest when they do face-to-face
interactions so you know and it's it's
not surprising
um you know we we're we're human we like
to interact with people
um but when you look over the course of
the day and you ask people at the end of
the day how happy they are
their happiness correlates very highly
with the amount of time that they spent
on Facebook now at the time we did the
study Facebook was the most common
social media used by this particular
group of people they were knowledge
workers all different work roles now how
do you explain that well it's
interesting we it it didn't seem right
to us that the more time on Facebook the
happier you are when you reflect on it
over the course of the day it also turns
out that when people are really engaged
in their work and they're you know they
have a lot of work to do when they need
to be focused
um it's actually better for them to do
something simple like social media that
doesn't require a lot of effort why
because people can be in control of
their attention to go in Facebook and
out when they need to when you're in an
interaction face-to-face you're not
always in control you can be a prisoner
in an interaction it's hard to be
impolite and suddenly cut yourself off
when you have a lot of work to do and so
for for times when you have a lot of
work to do you've got a deadline
something like face-to-face can actually
offer people a break but if they use it
strategically and they don't get stuck
in the rabbit hole I see yes so it's
like an on-demand
uh social break yeah you get well one of
the things that's kind of obvious is the
story I tell myself about my social
media use
constitutes the Lions share of what that
means to my life you know the time has
gone the hour that I spent watching the
space documentary has gone uh
I have the option to tell myself that
that was I deserve a break wanted a
break enjoyed a break it doesn't matter
let it go or I can lambast myself for
the next couple of hours saying you need
to grind your known and put your nose
against the grindstone in an attempt to
try and make up for it
um
have you looked at
sort of guilt and shame around our lack
of attention because
people's ability to self-flagellate that
I I should have worked harder I should
have done more God I finished today and
I didn't do as much as I should have
done and the reason for that was I was
just I'm so distracted I need to be more
disciplined let me listen to some Joker
willink and David Goggins motivational
videos I'm gonna put some rock music on
I'm gonna work until two in the morning
have you looked at this
yeah of course people feel terrible when
they spend a good part of their day on
social media and they feel that their
work is neglected uh that's that's not a
good thing right uh you know on the one
hand I'm saying people are happiest when
they do these these things that make
them engaged but you know it's not very
challenging but only if they do it
wisely and strategically and not spend
you know hours uh with their time doing
that so they have people have to learn
how to use these kinds of activities to
their benefit and it's really important
to be able to take good breaks so that's
that's something that people neglect to
do and we get ourselves exhausted we're
you know people can't hold sustained
Focus for lengthy periods in the same
way that we can't lift weights for
extended periods we get exhausted we are
mental resources get drained so we need
time to be able to take a break to be
able to step back and you you take
whatever break works for you right but
it's not a break that's
extensive if you've got a lot of work to
do you you have to put limits what does
a good break look like to you
the best break of all is to take a walk
in nature to go outside uh so you know
there's a really nice study that shows
20 minutes in nature makes people
less stressed relaxes them I've done a
study where we show that 20 minutes in
nature significantly increases people's
ability to generate ideas it's called
Divergent thinking and so the best break
of all is get out in nature I realize
that circumstances don't allow always
for going outside and I I know many of
the listeners might be living in places
right now where the weather speaking to
somebody that spent 33 years in the
northeast of England so yes yes correct
right
so um so there are other things we can
do it's always good to to get up to move
your body to you know stretch that's
always a great thing but you know if you
need a quick Break
um it's okay to do some mindless
activity it's okay to you know I have my
silly anagram game and and I and I do
that and it helps relax me the mind is
engaged it's lightly engaged and so you
can let ideas incubate in the back of
the mind
um there's the um
the the great writer Maya Angelou talks
about her big mind and little mind and I
I just love this she she says that her
big mind was used for her deep thought
and she really you know was challenged
and put in a lot of effort in her
writing it didn't come easy for her she
she said she wanted to strangle the
critics who said that the writing came
easy but then she had what she called
her little mind which is when she pulled
back took a break
uh relaxed did for her it was crossword
puzzles and it helped her replenish and
so you know if you look at a lot of
great
scientists and writers they all have
their kind of rote activity that they do
that helps them replenish and regenerate
and one of my favorites is the
philosopher Ludwig Wittgenstein who said
he got his best ideas when he peeled
potatoes
that was his rote activity right you're
lightly engaged right otherwise you'd
cut your finger but you know it it
enabled him to kind of his mind could
still turn uh he could think of ideas
and he was doing something very broad
you know what my favorite thing is so
when I take breaks if I've been in here
for too long I go outside and it's
usually beautifully sunny in Austin and
I've got a tennis ball and I just throw
a tennis ball against a wall on a
there's like a it's called a slack Block
it's like a slack line but you can
transport it so it's like a wobbly board
that you stand on and I can just throw
that against a wall and I am lightly
engaged but not too much it's not too
challenging it's a tennis ball against
the wall I could have done it when I was
five but one of the concerns that you
could have when we're talking about okay
so
um light engagement
bit of enjoyment don't be bored that's
your break the problem of using social
media as that is that social media is so
tempting and the rabbit hole goes so
deep that the break becomes greater than
the amount of time that you just worked
for that you're taking a break from So
You spiral down and doom scroll for the
remainder of the hour yeah totally agree
and this is where it's so important for
people to develop agency over their
actions so that they can control the
amount of time that they spend on these
kinds of activities especially social
media so people need to become more
intentional in their activities and you
can become more intentional by probing
yourself right when you when you have
this urge to go on social media you
probe yourself and ask yourself why do I
need to go there now is it because I
need a break is it because I'm bored
and okay it's fine you can give yourself
permission to go there but when you're
there continue probing yourself am I
still getting value out of this what
kind of value am I getting and you know
am I am I replenished you know do I feel
it's time for me to go back to work and
then get yourself back on track but you
have to keep yourself
um aware of what your actions are so
that you have more control over that
another thing that you can do is to
practice forethought and here's what I
mean by that
is to understand how your current
actions can affect your life Downstream
and the the best time frame is later in
the day or at the end of the day and so
if you're going to go on social media
and you know you're someone who can
spend an hour there or longer practice
forethought and say before I go there
what's my day going to look like am I
still going to be up working on that
deadline at 10 pm or am I going to be
relaxing with a glass of wine reading a
book watching my favorite show what's my
life later in the day going to look like
so practice thinking of your future self
when you have that urge to go on social
media you and David Goggins one of the
hardest men on the planet Navy SEAL and
ultra marathon runner have the same idea
so he calls it the one second decision
and the one second decision he um plays
forward what happens if he decides to do
this right now so he uses the example of
seal selection and he's on the beach in
California in freezing water and he is
tempted to ring the bell he wants to
leave he wants to get out he wants to
quit
he thinks what happens if I go and do
that well I'll be warm but I'm going to
be warm in five days in any case it's
only five days hell week so
what what happened I go up I ring the
bell then I get warm then I go to bed
what do I feel like when I go to bed
tonight well racked with shame and guilt
and insufficiency uh and the same thing
goes for this the the best question that
I asked myself and I got everyone that
listens to the show to ask during covid
was what would have had to have happened
by the end of lockdown for you to look
back on lockdown and consider it a
success and what I love about the idea
of
um forethought toward the end of the day
is for the most part when you get
distracted and when you do a distracting
activity like going on social media you
are
optimizing for pleasure in the moment
which will cause you discomfort in the
long term what you're doing with the
forethought exercise is you're reversing
that you're allowing some of that future
pain to get front loaded into this
decision-making process right now so
it's no longer as hidden I think that's
very very good that's right exactly
right yep
what
about how someone should design their
day if they want to maximize their focus
you know most people most days are
relatively similar relatively routinized
or at least weeks are same stuff same
sort of time if you were to design a day
to maximize Focus what would you do yeah
so first of all it turns out that we
found that people have rhythms over the
day for when their focus is at its peak
and you know most people have Peak Focus
late morning around 11 A.M and mid to
late afternoon 2 to 3 P.M
um and there are individual differences
if you're an early type your Peak focus
is much earlier in the day if you're a
late type it's much lighter so this is
just what uh rep what's representative
of most people
so one of the first things you can do is
to design your day to schedule those
tasks that are going to be the hardest
that require the most thought the most
creativity to schedule those around your
Peak Focus times
and you know for goodness sake don't
don't spend that time doing social media
or doing email but use it for doing work
that really requires mental effort
because you've got those resources at
that time and this kind of Rhythm you
know it it Ebbs and flows and it's you
know coincides with our mental resources
we you know gather up our mental
resources and then we you know expend
them and you take a nice lunch break
where you can get yourself replenished
you eat eat well then you can ramp
yourself up again and be ready to do
focused work now you should not schedule
things back to back without a break it's
just not good and we tend to think that
that's the way scheduling has always
been done let's let's pack the most we
can into the shortest amount of time put
ourselves on this tight schedule so we
can finish and I want us to reframe the
conversation and I want us to think
about putting our well-being first
because if we put our well-being first
we will be productive along the way and
that means also scheduling in important
time for breaks for Meaningful breaks
and I call this negative space uh you
know before I I got into science I
actually was trained as an artist
and when you when you do a painting you
think of of course the the figure you're
creating but also the space around that
becomes very important that space frames
the figure and it sets it off and if you
are familiar with the sculptor of Henry
Moore you know that's also an example
he's a
a British sculpture or uh most most
great artists and sculptures or even
Japanese Gardens make use of this idea
of negative space surrounding the rocks
in a garden
let's translate that into our day right
we've got hard work we want to do over
the day but we want to also schedule in
time that can maybe proceed and follow
this hard work
where you can replenish and you can use
that time you know whatever works for
you right it can be contemplation can be
taking a walk in nature can be doing
some uh Road activity but schedule that
in and consider that as important as the
tasks you're doing because that that
negative space or empty space in the day
is going to help your performance shine
also importantly those negative spaces
should not be filled doing social media
well
to fill them with social media I agree
what else have we missed what else in
terms of strategies that move the needle
the most for people's attention or Focus
haven't we got down
so we talked about sleep uh
intentionality meta awareness but what
about blood sugar level what about have
you looked at the the relationship
between foods that people eat and the
attention
so I I have not looked at that in my
research
um I do know that when people have a
sugar crash it affects their attention
uh even though I've I've not looked at
that in my research okay and then uh you
also talk about
um like this agentic Sovereign View and
it seems like the word is is almost like
intentionality right what what am I
doing right now is this the thing that
I'm supposed to be doing creating that
matter awareness being able to see
what's going on exactly yes and that's
and I do believe that people can develop
a skill for uh for this type of meta
awareness it might seem hard at first
you know I observe people in my research
and I'm a professional Observer of
people's behavior and I learned to
become a professional Observer of my own
behavior and I did it through practice I
believe it's a skill that anyone can
create can develop and it becomes second
nature you're probing yourself and it
just becomes second nature and it
becomes a habit for you and then it
enables you to become more intentional
when it whenever you have an urge to go
to social media you probe yourself it's
second nature and say why do I need to
go there
uh there there is another thing we could
talk about which is we we talked about
Solutions at the individual level but I
also think that there can be Solutions
at the collective level
so I you know
when it comes to electronic
communications you know I talked earlier
in the show that people you know have to
respond to the demands in the
environment and if anyone simply cuts
themselves off from you know email and
slack and Communications they actually
penalize themselves especially if you're
in the workplace because they're they
don't have access to important
information and so
I believe that organizations need to
come up with a solution
for example you know you can some
companies have email free days and
that's shown some promise uh you can
shrink the window of time for when
electronic communications are sent so
you know we've we've tested batching
which means sending email out you know
beginning of the day middle of the day
end of the day unfortunately we don't
find that it moves the needle doesn't
make people feel more productive or less
stressed but people do average checking
their emails 77 times a day and I do
think that a female is batched at least
people wouldn't be checking at 77 times
a day they might check it three times a
day yes as a collective that's going to
be difficult because as soon as one
person breaches that you now have a
Cascade of emails coming in well you can
turn off the the server the email server
so it's a hard stop yeah the hard stuff
you know another thing we can do is I'm
I'm very interested this notion of right
to disconnect laws and I France has it
Ontario has policy Ireland has policy
Believe It or Not New York City tried to
introduce a right to disconnect law and
uh Stupid idea that they had they had a
council meeting it was very interesting
um most businesses argued against it and
one of the most interesting arguments
was from the the Bureau of Tourism that
said the reason why New York City is the
number one tourist attraction is that
we're the city that never sleeps and
therefore you know workers should should
not turn off but you know a right to
disconnect law would would not punish
individuals who who choose not to answer
electronic communications after work
hours it helps people detach from work
and if you can detach from work you know
it gives you a break gives you a chance
to to replenish it's good for people's
well-being and as a result it helps
people more effectively reattach
the next day
Elements which is one of the shows the
sponsors on this uh on this podcast they
do three weeks on one week off
every employee
one problem being that if there's
something urgent that needs during doing
on the Monday of that one week
tough luck or on the Saturday on the
Saturday after the Friday of week three
it's a painful nine-day wait to get a
response from anyone and there's no one
in the office so that's an extreme
version of it but yeah I think you're
right on a collective level
um
we are individuals hairless Apes trying
to battle back against the most powerful
algorithms in history and billion dollar
companies with the smartest data
scientists on the planet powering them
yeah it's not quite a fair fight at the
moment and all of the any legislation
that we can have put in I think that
assists us to disconnect is probably a
smart idea I I agree but you know it's
ultimately people we we have created the
internet we contribute content and I
really think people have the power to
make change
Dr Gloria Mark ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the stuff that
you do where should they go
to my website
Gloria mark
one word
um and then uh you can learn a lot more
in my book attention span Linked In the
show notes below Gloria I appreciate you
thank you thank you so much for having
me what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]